[Music]
as Isis evaporates who deserves credit
well if you ask Donald Trump its Donald
Trump I totally changed rules of
engagement I totally changed our
military I totally changed the attitudes
of the military and they have done a
fantastic job the ISIS is now giving up
they're giving up they're raising the
hands they're walking off nobody's ever
seen that before that is classic Trump
so that's riled up the media who hate
his boasting thank God no one else ever
did that Osama bin Laden is dead and
General Motors is alive al Qaeda is on
the path to defeat and Osama bin Laden
is dead my opponent and his running mate
are new to foreign policy they want to
take us back to an era of blustering and
blundering that cost America so dearly
after all you don't call Russia our
number-one enemy not al Qaeda Russia
unless you're still stuck in a cold war
mind war that did not age well so should
you care if Donald Trump blows his own
horn again I'll take a win led by a
blowhard over a failure led by a
thoughtful academic but for the media
the story is always Trump's words and
not his deeds 2014 it seems long ago but
you must remember that time when Isis
sprang from hell that first beheading a
Valentine of evil
it's nothing we'd ever seen before and
the hip hits kept coming as our
commander and charm dismissed them they
flourished even after they've graduated
from JV to varsity now they're nearly
gone and only because we returned to a
simple truth annihilation Trump's
analysis all this matters in another
context North Korea President Trump is
facing the same gripes for his rhetoric
towards North Korea who said yesterday
again that were on the brink of nuclear
war it's been only Trump who's gotten
China's attention on this it's been only
Trump who's drawn a red line that few
doubt and so as with Isis it's only
Trump who has any hope of success here
because the
Association without leverage is it
negotiation its blather blather goddess
Isis it got us the Iranian nuke deal
blather got us a nuclear North Korea
there are some problems impervious to
blather so let the media blather on this
is a street fight on planet Earth Avenue
and ask yourself who would you rather
square off against a president who
promised to annihilate Isis and does it
or the professional blather errs
appalled when a president actually wins
one how can you deny the differences in
approach Dana
you really can't although I think that
there are probably some Obama
administration people would say well we
actually put this in motion right
October of 2016 and therefore we
actually deserve the credit this is what
they say about the economy right the
thing is that President Trump is doing
is that he is using the threat or the
actual action of military force in order
to make diplomacy more effective that's
the goal yeah and so it makes some
people feel uncomfortable I guess and
maybe whether in the media or elsewhere
I do think that this is a moment to
celebrate but there's not much time to
celebrate yeah because behind this is
the vacuum so we did we know one of the
things that brought people together to
fight Isis was the fact that we had all
these different coalition's working
together now they're all in the region
still and they're starting to turn on
each other yeah so what is our
diplomatic goal from there after this
military threat worked Kimberley
terrorists are like the devil's Doritos
we just keep eating him but they'll
he'll always make more oh my goodness
don't give Doritos a bad name so tasty I
feel a food court coming on Devil's
Doritos exactly so I think that this
isn't you know we talked about this you
know yesterday as well but the bottom
line is President Trump does deserve
credit for his accomplishments in terms
of really responding and listening to
the military listening to the people or
in the field who are on the ground and
actually putting in play and in motion
giving them the ability to run their
play which is this is how we want to
defeat them this is what's needed we
need to return the rules of engagement
to what they were before and we need to
be strategic in how we approach this and
not just use you know flowing rhetoric
actually get it done do you recall Greg
that people were criticizing
President Trump and say well where's
this plan where is the specific how is
he gonna get this done he's saying he's
gonna crush him but guess what
in fact he has so the actions and
instead of telegraphing exactly what
you're going to do and putting it in
place has proved to be much more
beneficial and effective the other thing
jesse is the way he talked about it
every when he talked about the wall that
had an effect on the Mules business I
can through build mules they stopped
coming from Central America IO tees or
mules mules or drugs
coyotes are people coyotes riding meals
ok yes so they see it diminished trap
need that kind of traffic
in a way his language had an effect on
Isis before perhaps the bombs did
perhaps it did you know I don't mind
when politicians take credit for success
it's when they point fingers when
there's failure yeah everybody does that
Trump's been saying the stock market
record highs it's all his responsibility
when that thing crashes I'm sure he's
going to be pointing fingers right and
then you have Obama you know I killed
bin Laden but then Isis crept up and
it's the CIA's fault because they missed
that it's fine he ran on knocking the
hell out of Isis so I don't mind if he
thumps his chest a little bit he can
accomplish a lot when Congress is not
involved imagine if Congress were
involved in the fight against Isis
they'd probably be in control of the
entire Middle East but I don't like the
hypocrisy about the media when Obama
came out and said you know what we don't
have a strategy and their JV the media
said oh you know what the rise of Isis
that's Bush's fault and then when he
took a really weak approach to this air
war and there was a stalemate the media
said you know what great job President
Obama we're not in a quagmire then he
sends boots on the ground media's silent
so Trump comes up says he's going to
wipe him off the face of the earth media
calls him naive and a warmonger then
Trump actually wipes them off the face
of Iraq and the media hasn't said
anything Juan I saw you nodding an
agreement with everything Jesse said
well there were some things I did agree
with but I must say the part that I
disagree with all of you about is that
he's doing something different because
essentially what he did was continue
Obama's strategy
and in fact what was let me just point
out that when Obama said we're going to
go into Moses we're gonna put more
people in there to support you know the
special Kurdish forces or whatever
they're in there
guess who opposed it Donald Trump that's
the fact so I mean I'm just like so he
comes in and he says I've got a secret
plan I got a secret plane I'm gonna get
rid of Isis these campaigns I got a
secret plan no secret plan inside this
plan Oh a secret plan you got a key no
but I see I see
we gotta move on why he said you know
what let's push is full Isis overthrow
iraq strategy that defeated them under
now let me just say Obama had a strategy
Trump continued it I think that where
credit is due to President Trump is that
President Trump was willing to go in not
with additional forces so much as
additional firepower from above that
wiped out these places mm-hmm you know
sponsored a lot of the immigration
flight that we're now concerned about in
the ground to know we can all celebrate
any time Isis I whereas a defeated yeah
and I will never I'm not celebrate till
it the entire idea is gone okay I agree
and it fell